some people eat to live and some people
live to eat I am definitely the latter
in other words I have been a lifelong
foodie I'm sure most of you have fond
childhood memories you know a first
bicycle or a lemonade stand my fondest
memory takes me back to when I was 3
years old
recovering from the flu my mother had
forbidden me from eating mangos
but my grandmother snuck me one anyway
and I remember ecstatically running out
of the kitchen mango all over my face
and straight into my mother I told her I
hadn't eaten any mangos of course and
even she couldn't help but smile
reflecting on my childhood I am flooded
with memories like this memories
connecting food with a love so ingrained
in my upbringing that I could not
conceive of human suffering stemming
from hunger but this changed when I
visited my father's ancestral village
and met the children of some of his
childhood friends my peers enrolled in
schools just for the meal programs in
stark contrast walking through the
Dining Commons at Penn State barely a
few days later I saw trays full of food
being thrown away and I remember feeling
appalled at the amount of food that was
being wasted that was the moment I
realized that our food systems are
broken but it's not just the disparity
between what we don't have and what we
throw away we see ample evidence of our
broken food systems right here in our
own supermarkets I'm sure most of you
are used to seeing this but coming from
a culture where a milkman brought us our
one type of milk along with a cow to our
house every morning this dairy fridge
took me from odd confusion faster than a
Tesla can go from zero to 60 but this
fridge exists to cater to a wide array
of consumer
references because you and I don't make
food choices the same way you could be
thinking about health outcomes and
buying organic food you could be
thinking about environmental
sustainability and going local you could
be thinking about economic fairness and
going Fairtrade and the folks at the
back could be thinking about intangibles
like taste or color I like to think of
this as our food value hierarchy but
most of us share one fundamental value
in this hierarchy I'm sure you all know
what it is
price food retailers do as well so low
cost has been a predominant driver in
this industry for decades but as some of
the other values have started rising in
importance food retailers are extremely
slow to catch up why is that what is it
that needs to be fixed so I asked the
GSB community to tell me what they
thought needed to be fixed what was
broken with our food system and how they
would fix it wave a magic wand as it
were and then I went and spoke to
thought leaders and food advocates I
actually working to reform the food
system 80% of the GSB community that I
spoke to said that healthy food was
inaccessible unaffordable or
environmentally unsustainable the food
advocates agreed but I want to frame
this problem slightly differently how is
it possible that a vegetable that has
grown halfway across the world can be
produced harvested packaged marketed
transported and distributed at a price
point that is cheaper than a vegetable
that has grown sustainably just miles
from here the answer is simpler than you
think the food we eat is so cheap
because it has become a commodity grown
in a rigged economic system a system
that reallocates the cost of negative
impacts of production from the cash
register to our tax dollars and the
industrial complex the churns out this
food is big and it's made it so easy
first
prioritize cheap and unhealthy food
instead of demanding healthy and
sustainable food in fact the cards are
so highly stacked against resilient
farming systems that I fear that they
will never break through to become
mainstream unless we change our buying
behaviors and I hear you thinking this
is great Ruthie but I'm one consumer
against an entire system isn't that what
legislations for what can I possibly do
I hear you but I disagree because turns
out you can do a lot I have two
suggestions first recognize the cost of
industrial II produced food a pound of
conventional chicken cost about a dollar
fifty at the grocery store a pound of
premium chicken cost closer to two
dollars and seventy cents much more
expensive but as consumers we don't pay
the full price of that conventional
chicken because it's hidden in our tax
bill I've spent years thinking about
this problem and after wrestling with
data from the UN Environment Programme
the sustainable food trust the food tank
you name it I've come to realize that
when you add the cost of negative impact
so this could be the cost of runoff
clean up at factory farms incremental
health care costs associated with
antibiotic resistance in the country
that pound of conventional chicken gets
closer to two dollars and sixty cents
not that far off from premium chicken in
fact on average when you add these
negative externalities that's a 2 X
multiplier on the sticker price of any
conventionally produced food product
we're all familiar with NPV I like to
think of this as the future value of our
present choices and yes you don't pay
these hidden costs today but imagine a
future where you can't get cardiac
surgery because you have bacteria that
is resistant to all the antibiotics in
the market or a future where your child
is suffering from chronic asthma because
of environmental pollution and imagine
knowing then that your food choices in
the past had something to do with it so
think about that the next time you reach
for that industrial chicken off the
grocery
well maybe now you're thinking that the
price value that you place so much
emphasis on isn't quite right so
identify your other food values I'm
considering adding maybe just one more
to your hierarchy I like to think of
this as value training wheels
this could mean different things for
each of us if you tend to buy
prepackaged meals identify a store that
you can trust to curate a collection of
these meals that will embody your food
values for you I know I rarely look at
product labels when I shop at Trader
Joe's or Whole Foods because I know
they've done some of the thinking for me
but I also love to cook my roommate told
me last week that I tend to cook for at
least 10 people every week even at the
GSB some of you are sitting here thank
you for coming when I shop for groceries
I tend to prioritize health outcomes so
I decided to add my value training
wheels and went local last week my
grocery bill went up by 12 dollars that
is the price of three cappuccinos at
Kupa 80% of you said that you would be
willing to add that one value to your
hierarchy so why don't you go and try it
for a week if you buy based on price now
try to go local if you already buy local
try to go antibiotic free see how little
your bill changes because the true
drivers of change in the food system are
those of us sitting at the dining table
and when we as consumers buy products
that are aligned with sustainable food
values we create a demand that food
companies will respond to and farmers
will respond to the buying power of
these food companies
everybody wins just think about the
replacement of styrofoam cups with paper
cups the abolition of DDT in the United
States or even the more recent mass and
expansion of uber into several cities
despite crippling political pressure all
of these changes started with one voice
the powerful voice of a consumer your
voice so whether or not we acknowledge
it we have the power to vote with our
wallets so we might as well do it
intentionally
and yes these food choices are a
conscious investment in an alternative
and resilient farming system but they're
also an investment in a better future
for you a future where access to healthy
fresh and delicious food is a
fundamental right for everybody
and not just for those of us who can
afford to pay the premium and because at
the heart of it all we are what we eat
and what I am is a lifelong foodie and
maybe you are too because you love food
just like me but as you leave this talk
I want to implore you to become a farm E
as well so that you can change the
system more than the system has changed
you thank you